that has led to a renewed push to get
people to get vaccinated christian
casaras
here with more on those efforts
christian well brian governor steve
silac is urging nevadans to get
vaccinated to push
forward he says the resources are
available to get tested to get the
vaccine
now it's up to each person to make it
happen with the increase in positive
covet 19 cases and
the delta variant full state and health
officials are reminding
everyone of the get out the vaccine
efforts in southern nevada
the governor reiterated the f the
effects of the deadly virus have not
changed but by working together to
increase confidence in the vaccine we
can bring the covet cases down
according to one doctor this will
prevent health restriction rollbacks
similar to those l.a county just issued
these vaccines have worked against all
the variants that's the message
we need to be driving home to people
right now if there's
not that many uh people left to be
infected and there's not that much delta
variant here you know i think it's a
little bit of a false alarm at this
point
governor steve says like also reminding
everyone about the 5 million dollars in
prices raffle the grand price
is 1 million now anyone who gets at
least
one dose of the covet 19 vaccine gets
automatically entered
winners will be announced every thursday
starting july 8th through august
26th christian casadas 8 news now